foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I like it keep going happy Tuesday
everybody we're only about 80 Tuesdays
away from the next presidential election
so what a coincidence that an 80 year
old officially announced he's running
today huh
an ambitious move from a man so old he
shouldn't buy green bananas
still Joe Biden made his formal
announcement and you could tell it was
formal because it depends how to
cumberbund
Freedom fundamental to who we are as
Americans and there's nothing more
important
personal freedom is fundamental to who
we are as Americans there's nothing more
important nothing more sacred that's
been the work of my first turn to fight
for our democracy this shouldn't be a
red Revolution
all right fine but you know around the
country aren't Maga extremists lining up
to take on those Bedrock freedoms
but you know around the country magnet
extremists are lining up to take on
those Bedrock freedoms cutting Social
Security that you paid for your entire
life while cutting taxes from the very
wealthy dictating what health care
decisions women can make Banning books
and telling people who they can love all
while making it more difficult for you
to be able to vote ugh I call that
poppycock but that's what Hunter calls
his penis
[Laughter]
it's amazing that Biden even slurs his
words in recordings that are made with
heavy editing I mean even John fetterman
is like dude get that guy to a doctor
[Laughter]
and no a real doctor oh God
it's more of the same crap that half the
countries irrevocably evil it's like
when you ran for president four years
ago it said we were going to battle for
the soul of America are we still doing
that
when I ran for president four years ago
I said we're in a battle for the soul of
America and we still are
the question we're facing is whether in
the years ahead we have more freedom or
less freedom more rights are fewer yeah
is that a quote Sam Brinton after
stealing your mom's luggage
let's unpack that
he was elected four years ago and we're
still battling for the soul of America
we're still losing freedoms and that's
your selling point that your president
promising that you unify the country and
instead it got worse it's like the movie
groundhog day except Biden never sees
his shadow because he's asleep by 4 pm
and so once again he revs up the never
Trump campaign engine like it's a
Corvette parked on a pile of classified
documents
but just because the vote for me I'm not
the other guy Engel worked last time
doesn't mean it will again because now
he's the other guy too he has a track
record and it's uglier than Joy Behar
trying on Brian stelter's Underpants
yeah think about that huh no wonder his
numbers suck 70 of Americans don't want
him to run there's doubts among his own
party he'll be 86 by the end of his
second term a man that age should retire
to spend time with the grandkids at
least the ones he acknowledges
yeah
fact is Jimi Hendrix would be 86 at the
end of Biden's term and he's aging
better
back to Joe's video where the only thing
grainier than the footage was the
Adderall they matched into his pudding
so is it not time to be complacent and
is that why you're running for
re-election
this is not a time to be complete
[Music]
that's why I'm running for re-election
and this is our moment so if you're with
me go to Joe biden.com
finish this job I know we can let's
finish the job
that's usually what a villain says
before they kill the family
[Laughter]
it's one of the worst slogans I've heard
since Bud Light switched to the queen of
beers
because with Biden what does finish the
job really mean when so far him doing
his job brought us hyperinflation
never-ending illegal immigration an
explosion of fentanyl overdoses and
rampant crime you couldn't come up with
a better plan to destroy America if you
brainstormed with Putin and president XI
over some Kung Pao bors
and he didn't even mention Kamala maybe
he forgot her name
or he sees a half Jamaican woman and
thinks oh she's his home health aide
I know racist right
seriously he gave her a lower profile
than Dana Dana Perino in a cornfield
so I guess it left Kamala no choice but
to drop an announcement video of her own
I'm actually running for president too
and I'd be honored to be your
commander-in-chief
because what this country needs right
now is for our chiefdom to be commanded
from our effective policies and border
control to galvanizing more and more
yellow school buses I will continue to
build back better
and bigger and faster than we've ever
built back bigger and better before they
are America we are united
and without Joe Biden on this ticket we
are less handicapped
pretty accurate to me
but Joe needs all the help he can get
but don't take my word for it take it
from this guy you know I wonder if you
took the five worst Presidents in
history would Joe be worse than all of
them
you could take the five worst Presidents
in American history and put them
together and they would not have done
the damage Joe Biden has done to our
nation in just a few short years wow is
it not even close
not even close
[Applause]
his greatest contribution to mankind
getting Don Lemon fired 2024 GOP
Presidential candidate and author of the
new book capitalist punishment
she talks so fast she uses anti-skid lip
gloss host of the fox True Crime podcast
Emily componu
thank you
he gets startled by unfamiliar noises
like applause comedian Joe Mackey
and audiences treat him like family by
walking out on him
Dr writer comedian Jamie lissow
So Jamie good to see you you know
political experts actually say that Joe
has a better chance of winning than you
getting back with your wife wow
that's uh that's surprising what did you
make in the video I it was first of all
I feel like he only said one word the
whole video but it was like a long one
yes do you know what I mean like does
his speech writer not have a space bar I
felt like the whole thing was like
hassle strassles it was just one thing I
could I could not follow along
um let's finish the job if I hear that
one more time after sex
[Applause]
I don't know he's not he's he's too old
I heard he was at the doctor recently
and the doctor told him he had nine
months to live and Joe was like am I
sick and the doctor was like no that's
just how life expectancy works
um
when I that was good terrible when you
hear when you first hear the story
though do you not go like I think we all
want to reach a point in our lives where
we rest yeah and spend time with family
like he's 80 years old like wouldn't you
wanna I was thinking like why wouldn't
he want to spend time with his kids then
I was like oh Hunter's this kid yeah
and he's got a stripper baby grandchild
yes that's right yeah the fake uh what
did you make of the ad it's interesting
he seems to make again the enemy of the
people the people it's not about China
or or fentanyl it's about half of
America yeah well the thing I made of
the ad is it has a farce at the heart of
it that Joe Biden's actually running for
president yeah Joe Biden's actually not
running for president just looks like he
is it's the managerial class in this
country that has put out this little
puppet called Joe Biden running for
president that makes sense of his
cognitive deficits right that's not a
bug to them that's a feature because
that allows the Puppet Master to control
the puppet Susan Rice steps down the day
before and so this elder abuse and I
think that's what it looks like to me
elder abuse it's just a cost of doing
business if you're the managerial class
that's how you roll and the DNC is
protecting him by the way they're not
doing debates yeah they're not going to
let anybody challenge the hollowed out
husk of a supposed human being and
leader that we have in that white house
and I think a big part of the reason why
why is it's not even him it's just the
Wizard of Oz he's a projection yes he's
an empty vessel Emily if that's your
real name no mention a Kamala that was
weird I guess maybe they just didn't
have time
I mean he probably doesn't know who his
vice president is I have to say that the
most concerning thing to me about it was
the I literally asked myself the
question when I saw it is this a repeat
like when I saw it on air are we
repeating two years ago what his
campaign ads were right he has not
changed one bit and for someone that
campaigned on being the unifier in Chief
for him to show as the extremists on his
new campaign ad other elected officials
current serving elected officials and he
was the one that was supposed to unite
us I noticed that the majority of the
people in the ad were African-American
remember he told them when he ran the
first time you're not black if you don't
vote for me and he's still trying to
cater to and Pander to this narrative
that pitches him apparently this Elite
managerial class against America what's
wrong with the American flag what's
wrong with me standing up for it
standing up for Faith he asks whether or
not we want freedoms yes he's taken all
of it away his administration has
diminished our rights our freedoms our
choices he's bloated our government he's
is diminished the value of the dollar
there was Zero specificity in that ad
because he has accomplished nothing and
you talk about shouldn't he rest he has
been resting he has done nothing in his
50 years of service and so I look
forward to once a GOP candidate gets in
office in two years to actually doing
something and restoring my rights and my
freedoms
[Applause]
do it it's a tough act to follow oh man
I can't go after campagnol uh I'll tell
you what Craig when I heard that
recording it sounded to me like
something uh that would be recording
when someone's recording a will yeah
yes it's like I don't have much time
left
and they brought a phone to this
hospital bed
and got me to do this on a number of
takes I imagine there were a number of
tapes to make that recording and it
wasn't even good but at least when you
have multiple takes he doesn't do that
thing which I saw him do again today
where he starts one sentence and then he
pauses in the middle and then finishes a
completely different I love that it's
like a Maroon 5 song where it's pop
music at the start and then suddenly rap
starts playing except this time it's
destroying America
all right
we got to move on we got a great show we
got some surprises but if I told you
they wouldn't be surprises hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else